right after I propose to her she goes I
want to take a picture with my new ring
on in the ocean you know social media
wants that moment that was not the
moment where the ring got lost thank
goodness I proposed because I was
begging for like years it was back and
forth for the last three years it was
cheaper to get married then to buy
another plane ticket so here we are
and also he loves me I know so I love
her I was on New Year's Eve when I
proposed we were only seven months into
dating nobody was pregnant
we got to center first like week of
marriage sleeping in a small tent and so
that was kind of our adventure who lost
the ring and had it been Molly Molly
lost the ring okay it was stolen it was
not stolen I asked my aunt if I could
have my grandmother's wedding ring to
give to Jackie she was like put the ring
in your backpack she said to me right
Jamie I'm gonna give you this ring but
please don't lose it the first ring I
ended up being allergic to the metal I'd
take any old ring and I went and
exchanged it and bought like a really
nice like traditional ring I wasn't
allergic to the middle of that one um I
was allergic to this style of that way I
was living with my roommate Erin and I
was watching her dogs because she was
out of town put it next to my bed and in
the morning it was not there and I look
at these sweet dogs and they weren't so
sweet anymore but in my gym bag safe did
a really hard workout
yes I'm amazing go back to the gym bag
and it was gone my ring was the
showpiece it was rose gold diamond bath
it with her theory hurts me to hear to
talk about it go on the train put my bag
next to me fell asleep and then I heard
the announcer announce my stop and I
jumped off of the train went up the
escalators and it was when I got to the
top that I realized I didn't have my bag
which had the wedding ring so I don't
know who has my wedding ring but I hope
they're enjoying it yeah for two and a
half days was going through all the poop
of these dogs like really feeling the
hotness of it and I could not find this
ring and then I look in between my bed
and
bedside table and my ring is wedged in
between I had no idea that this even
happened took it off to shower and it
fell down the sink you have to call the
whole plumber thing and then like he was
searching for it couldn't find it you
said it fell down a sink or the shower
the sink the bathroom sink okay did you
have the ring did you not lose that ring
it's gone
obviously it's gone but I don't know
where it is uh-huh
I don't I don't know where when well
whatever I mean it's my wife all over to
death so no matter if I gotta buy a ring
every year
[Music]
please tell me my lost ring isn't
anything this one's pretty it looks like
my actual ring I like can you can stack
these what I think this would be awesome
for like working out and stuff cuz
always leave my ring at home they make
me want to go rock climbing after I lost
my ring I was panicking so I casually
throw out the hey we should get these
kalo rings this is the most fun I've had
all week
[Music]